while i was a graduate student and
before i
actually finished up my phd work and
then began
my my work as an academic professor
in a traditional well not completely
traditional
role because i was teaching in a prison
but at least as an assistant professor
teaching for ball state
i got an interest in the writings of
thomas hobbes the
author you may know of leviathan if
there's only one phrase that you
associate
with him it's the idea that life is
nasty brutish and short and obviously he
didn't actually think that about all
life
just life outside of a workable
commonwealth where you have a strong
authority figure all that's to the side
one of the things that i would do and
many academics do this
while i was in my my first job and i
continued doing this throughout my
career was go to conferences
and conferences were really kind of a
treat because you could go and listen to
other people's papers
you'd get to present your own get some
feedback from people
some of the things that i presented at
conferences on hobbs
ended up getting published in in
journals later on down the line
and even more than that though it was a
way to
connect up and make contacts with your
academic peers you know the first job
that i had
out of graduate school i was teaching in
a maximum security prison
in a degree program so you know they
earned a ba
from ball state university but you
wouldn't you know the students were
great but you wouldn't get a lot of
interaction with fellow academics who
were interested in the sorts of things
that you were
i did have a few you know friends among
the faculty
you know one who also did philosophy and
religious studies another who was in
political science but you know you could
only do so much with that
so it was fun to go and you know be on a
panel and present papers and then get to
chit chat about it afterwards and
have a meal or have some drinks with
people and then you know go off to your
hotel
you know hit the rack go to sleep get up
the next morning do it again for a while
so
that's what i would do and
i didn't just go to philosophy
conferences because i had an interest in
political theory both in terms of thomas
hobbes and
more contemporary stuff and also
aristotle i would go to political theory
conferences and one of the biggest
is the midwest political science
association
makes the you know national philosophy
uh the american philos philosophical
association their eastern
conference the eastern division
conference look like nothing because
there's so many people doing political
theory so i would go to that not least
because it was located every year in
chicago there's
a hotel that gets used by a lot of
conferences the palmer house hilton
right downtown very expensive of course
so i never actually stayed there um and
and i would go to conferences there and
and
i went to quite a few including the
central apa
i went to the midwest political science
association conferences there
and those would go on for four days and
i would drive
up from northwestern indiana
up to chicago taking you know the skyway
and parking downtown and all that it was
kind of a fun thing
and i every year that i applied i i got
a paper in so that was
really quite cool for me
and i would be on these panels and one
of the things that was really
interesting for me was seeing how
different disciplines would do this this
whole paper presenting thing
in philosophy you get your paper
generally and you've got it in front of
you and you just basically read it word
for word
although that's changing a bit these
days and in political
theory or political science it doesn't
work like that at all
on a panel you will have anywhere from
like
three to five main presenters
and each of them gets anywhere from like
you know
10 to maybe 20 minutes to present their
entire paper
the paper itself might be 40 pages long
which would take a very long time to
read and then you have
several respondents whose job is to read
the other people's papers and then say
something intelligent about it later
and then you have a chair and the chair
is supposed to be the person like
keeping track of everything making sure
nobody goes beyond their time
introducing everybody
and in general like being almost like
the ambassador
and mc for the whole session so it's
quite a performance
and it was you know a lot of fun to
participate in these things i got to
meet a lot more people at the political
science conferences because the panels
would be much larger in philosophy
they might be two to three people this
you're guaranteed to have like
five to seven people on a panel and some
of them can be a bit standoffish
particularly if they're older professors
and they think that you know this is
just like
doing some service but i met a lot of
cool people doing that
there's one session that i wanted to
tell a story about
because it was so funny
and also in some respects typical
of the sort of person who who
did this academic faux pas so
it was a panel and if i remember right
it was about the state of nature in
general so there were papers on
thomas hobbs i presented a paper on
thomas hobbs and then there was
there was stuff on lock and i think a
few other
early modern theorists and the chair was
one of the people presenting and that
was kind of weird right to begin with
because usually
the chair doesn't present the chair is
there to just sort of run things
but this guy was sort of a big name kind
of a big
muckety mock he was from the london
school of economics which
if you don't know is rather prestigious
compared to many other places
and people who work in those sorts of
elite institutions
often think that you know they matter
more than everybody else
and you know why wouldn't they everybody
else talks to them as if they do
and so they get kind of swelled heads
about about themselves and
that was the case with this guy and it
wasn't just being from the london school
of economics or talking with his posh
british
british accent or you know the way that
he sort of like kind of like
just ran his eyes over us and was like
okay that's that's
what we're gonna do today there was
something that happened a couple times
during the actual um
the the the panel presentation that
really stuck
stood out and and uh i'll tell you about
what happened and what he did and our
reactions
and then you know maybe muse a little
bit about what went on
so everybody was doing their papers you
know and then it came to his point where
he's like actually doing his paper
and so this would be like the early
2000s like 2004
2005 2006. and he's reading his paper
the little press see that he's made of
it beforehand right he's not reading the
entire thing
and his cell phone goes off and back
then cell phones were not the
smartphones they're you know usually
these flip phones
and you know okay so somebody's cell
phone going off that that
became a kind of constant thing that
would happen in movie theaters and
you know plays and stuff like that some
people just forget to turn their cell
phones off it's there's really nothing
wrong with
it now what do you do when your cell
phone goes off
if you're a decent civilized human being
who is respectful of others time and the
circumstances that you're in you know
you might look at it and be like oh i
don't have to i don't have to take this
call just turn it off you know
well instead he actually answered it so
he stopped his
his presentation and he didn't even say
anything like excuse me or anything like
that
just looked at his cell phone answered
it and we thought oh this must be like a
major emergency like his house is on
fire
or his kid fell down a well or who knows
what it is
and he just starts chatting with the
person and
we're all looking at each other like
what the hell is this
is there something wrong with this guy
does he he's the chair
he's the person who's supposed to be
like staying on top of making sure
everybody else is doing what they're
supposed to be doing and instead
he is committing this breach of
etiquette
and we're watching him and finally he he
gets to the end of his conversation okay
well i'll i'll talk with you later and
he clicks it off
doesn't apologize doesn't bat an eye
just
puts his phone down picks up his paper
and starts reading again and we're all
looking at each other like
what the f what's going on with this
well
maybe it's because he's an older person
and just
you know doesn't understand proper
etiquette when it comes to cell phones
and these sorts of things
maybe it is because he's from the london
school of economics so he thinks that
he's better than everybody else and his
time is more valuable
maybe there's just something wrong in
his brain like you know he's he's
losing it in some way right so he goes
on he's reading his paper some more by
the way his paper was not particularly
interesting or good
but two minutes later his cell phone
goes off again and now we're like
oh he's definitely not going to answer
this i mean he should have turned his
cell phone off the first time
and he stops again picks up his cell
phone
answers it it's a different person
because he's having a different
conversation
and he goes on for about a minute and a
half while all of us are like wow
this we're trying not to laugh at this
guy
and i'll talk a little bit more about
that later because we're all having you
know kind of strange
uh responses to this and we did talk
about it afterwards
and he talks on the phone with this
person and obviously it's not an
important conversation it's something
rather trivial then he says
sort of the damning words he says well
i'm presenting a paper at a conference
so i can't talk anymore i'm gonna have
to let you go
and he hangs up and now we're like well
it's not as if he doesn't know what he's
doing
clearly he understands exactly what
what's happening here
and what he's doing then he finishes
like the next you know three minutes of
his paper
and that's it and then you know we go on
to the next thing
nobody said anything because i think
nobody
including myself had any idea of what it
was that we should say
should we confront this guy and say you
were really kind of a jerk
and what's the deal you're the person
who's supposed to be preventing
jerkiness so what what was going on
there
you know and none of us actually really
knew him
so we knew him by reputation but none of
us knew him personally so we didn't
we didn't want to ask like was that joe
that you were talking to
or michael or you know your wife or
or what he never said a word about it
and you know a few of us afterwards as
we're walking away we're talking with
ourselves we're
between ourselves and we're like what
did what were you what were your
reactions to that
and there's oh i could see that you were
trying not to laugh
and why were we trying not to laugh well
because what he was doing was so clearly
out of place and he was the person who
was supposed to be preventing that but
instead he was doing it
and so it was kind of comedic on the one
hand like watching somebody who just
doesn't have any class
and yet he's coming from this place
where they're all sort of
you know at least by reputation poshy
posh people you know the upper class
and uh supposed to be you know
representing an illustrious institution
not like the rest of us schlubs coming
from
wherever right and so it was so
incongruous that we we didn't really
know
what to make of it and when we were
comparing notes later
afterwards talking over a beer everyone
had had the same reaction they were like
well i thought maybe you would say
something no i thought you would say
something
and then everyone was like i was trying
just not to start laughing because i
didn't want to
you know if there was something like
actually wrong with him i didn't want to
hurt his feelings on the other hand he
was being kind of a jerk
and i don't think i should be like you
know laughing about him
being a jerk and so none of us knew what
to do
i mean i think if i'm in a situation
like that again i probably would react
differently
but none of us at the time had any idea
about
what was going on or what we should do
and and
so i'm not going to say that you know we
should like view this as a
you know humanity writ large moment or
anything like that but
you know i don't even know the guy's
name anymore it's so long ago but if i
ever ran into him i probably would ask
him about it
and i certainly would judge him for the
behavior that he displayed at that time
but who knows it could have been just
like the one day that he
behaved in a crazy foolish
manner or maybe he's like that all the
time
it's going to be kind of a mystery
you